I think nobody will be surprised if I
say that immigration is one of the most
important issues in international
politics and certainly both in Europe
and in the United States lately.
Everything related to this issue takes
over most of the news and the front
pages of the newspapers.
Immigration was the fault.
All of the problems that were happening.
What the administration has decided to
do is to separate children from their
parents to try to send a message that if
you crossed the border with children,
your children are going to be ripped
away from you.
That's traumatizing to the children for
innocent victims and it is contrary to
our values and this country.
The United States will not be a migrant
camp and it will not be a refugee
holding facility will be because will be
able to push that open door space at
Columbia when she got down to granted.
Granted all window,
not deep
without going any further.
Here are visual politic.
We've already spoken a few times about
this objects and soon we're going to
post a special video first on our
Patrion and then on youtube commenting
and dismantling.
Many of the myths and half truths that
exist on this subject,
and just before we get into the meat of
today's video,
speaking of Patriot on,
let me thank everyone who is supporting
us on Patrion and everyone who just
watches us whereabouts across the half
million subscriber mark,
so that's pretty amazing and we couldn't
do that without you,
especially the people who do support us.
Like I say on Patrion.
Because of that,
we are now publishing 50 percent more
videos and we're now preparing lots of
surprises and of course all of the other
things that we have promised you,
but for now,
let's just crack on you at this time.
I'd like to share some reflections with
you,
some ideas which I think we should keep
in mind when we're talking about
immigration.
This is particularly important.
If we consider that lately mistrust,
fear and anti-immigration,
political speeches.
Well,
the very much alive
get out of my country,
I can still hear that sentence with
absolute clarity as if it occupies a
specific place in my mind.
It's a scar deep within.
The man who said,
get out of my country was a trump
supporter.
I know this because he was wearing a pin
identifying the then candidate on one of
his lapels,
but most of all,
I know this because of the way he said
it to me.
He looked me straight in the eyes,
pointed a finger at me and shouted,
or he a journalist
from univision and a US citizen who was
born in Mexico.
One of the most typical and popular
arguments of those who oppose
immigration is stating that immigrants
take odd jobs and take the money back to
their own countries.
You know,
as long as we're not talking about messy
you Christiane,
or analogy,
I know doll or maybe the writing stones
there.
Of course there's no problem,
which is perhaps a bit hypocritical,
don't you think?
So now we come to the question,
well,
why do people decide to emigrate?
Who are these people who pack their bags
and leave their land?
Who benefits from all of these
movements?
And in general,
why is that such a negative perception
of this phenomenon?
Well then this video,
I'm going to try and answer some of
those questions,
but first I think it's time we took a
look back at how it all began,
when,
why,
and where.
By the way,
what would you say if I told you that in
some way your also an immigrants?
Well,
listen up.
The origin from the very beginnings of
humanity,
people moved.
Basically their motivation was to find
food which forced them to move
continuously from one place to another.
Of course,
back then borders didn't exist.
The only limitation to moving from one
place to another with how far one could
travel.
Of course,
all this began to change when modern
societies emerged.
That is when communities settled in a
particular place where they worked to
produce food tools and everything they
needed to trade to live.
No.
One thing we can ask ourselves here is,
did the migration phenomenon disappeared
with this new way of life?
Well,
no,
not at all.
Once the first modern societies
established themselves in certain places
and governments began to emerge back
around 3000 BC,
migration didn't stop.
All the motivations did change to large
migration groups were created,
so to speak,
to groups with really different
motivations.
On the one hand that was conquering and
on the other hands,
there was searching for opportunities.
Yes,
the first conquest swerve movements
carried out by societies that had
achieved a higher level of developments
and who wanted to take advantage of it
to gain wealth from the people they call
it
good
involved a migratory movement from the
most developed countries to the less
developed countries to monopolize their
resources.
Although this phenomenon wasn't
exclusive to any continent,
the case that we all know best is
perhaps that of the Europeans who
managed to control almost the entire
world starting with America,
of course,
this type of migration,
it doesn't look anything like the
migration that we have today.
The second type of migration though it
certainly does.
We're talking about the peaceful
mobilization of millions of people who
seek to escape that territory of origin
to reach another territory where they
can find new and better opportunities.
In this case,
their drive is to search for economic
improvements and sometimes also to
escape political and religious
persecution.
Therefore,
in general,
we're talking about peaceful migrations
from the least developed countries to
the most developed countries,
which is something like the opposite of
conquest.
The first launch case happens at the end
of the Middle Ages when cities grew and
people began to leave the country side
to move to these cities.
In many case this,
it was a really slow process,
but everything changed with the arrival
of the industrial revolution.
It's estimated between 1850 and 1930,
almost $60 million Europeans,
which was a huge percentage of the
population at that time,
emigrated to the Americas countries like
the US,
Canada,
Brazil,
and Argentina.
That's is
to say,
despite all the political discourse
against immigration,
the truth is that Europe has a well
defined history as an emigrant
territory.
Europeans first emigrated massively from
the countryside to the cities.
Then they moved around the wells and is
now in our times.
Millions and millions of Europeans have
left their lands to live in another
European Union country.
And what about the United States?
Almost all of its population,
if not all of it,
comes from other countries or lives in
territories that belonged to other
countries,
as is the case of the lands of
California,
New Mexico and Texas,
which historically belonged to Mexico.
So in a way we're all really the
descendants of immigrants.
In fact,
if we take the current anti immigration
demonstrations TV extreme,
we could state that we are all
immigrants in the regions in which we
live.
Now,
the question we must ask is,
well,
what are the consequences of all of
that?
Could it have something to do with the
fact that most of the richest and most
developed countries in the wells have
been exposed to the migratory process?
Well,
listen up,
what history tells us what's that loud
or say a clear.
Most immigrants share a common goal to
achieve a better life and more progress.
It's true,
some people with deep pockets or a good
standard of living move from their
country to grow professionally,
have new experiences or maybe just live
differently.
These immigrants who usually arrive with
a full wallet almost never awakened
anyone's mistrust.
However,
same does not
apply to people who are escaping hunger,
misery,
all kinds of political,
religious,
and social prosecutions.
These are immigrants who arrive with an
empty wallet in search of new
opportunities.
This type of immigration is by far the
most important and of course the one
that generates the greatest mistrust,
hostility and criticism.
However,
this immigration is almost identical to
our ancestors.
We talking about people who are risking
their lives and who decided to leave
everything behind,
which is certainly not easy,
and all for what?
Well the same as always do,
achieve a better future to work and to
prosper in a lawful way.
It'll is more extraordinary than the
decision to migrate the accumulation of
emotions and thoughts which finally
leads a family to say farewell to a
community where it has lived for
centuries to abandon old ties and
familiar landmarks and to sail across.
Doc sees to a strange land.
John F Kennedy,
president of the United States of
America.
Tell me who built America,
who promoted the extraordinary economic
take off this?
Argentina saw at the end of the 19th
century.
Well,
folks,
it was the immigrants and the
descendants of the immigrants,
so why do we think of things as
different today,
but of course,
when economic data shows that
immigration drives growth and
development,
do youtube,
higher employment levels,
entrepreneurship and productivity,
then anti-immigration critics,
well,
they make up other excuses.
We're going to talk about them one by
one in a future video with data and
hands,
but today I'd like to end this video
with a reflection on one of the most
important myths,
fear and crime.
When Mexico sends its people,
they're not sending their best.
They're not sending you.
They're sending people that have lots of
problems and they're bringing those
problems with us.
They're bringing drugs,
they're bringing crime,
they're rapists.
One of the most widely spread myths is
that immigrants,
especially undocumented immigrants,
the so called illegals,
are the ones responsible for most crimes
and delinquency.
Well,
you know what?
The data actually says that the opposite
is true.
Now,
it is true that there are legal and
illegal immigrants who commit crimes.
However,
let's look at an example.
Let's look at what happens in the
country with the most immigrants in the
world.
The United States say between 1990 and
2013,
the number of undocumented immigrants
known as illegal immigrants went from
three and a half million people to
approximately 11 million.
However,
in that same period,
according to the FBI,
the number of violent crimes dropped by
48 percent.
Surprised well,
if we take the crime data into accounts,
he really shouldn't be.
So according to an immigration policy
center study,
only one point six percent of immigrant
men aged 18 to 39 end up in prison.
Among those born in the United States,
the data is three point three percent,
so more than double Jack.
This graph on crime levels in taxes,
which is one of the states with the most
legal and illegal immigrants.
Yes,
we can agree that we need to reorder the
migratory processes,
but stigmatizing immigrants and
outlawing their condition only favors
the human trafficking.
Matthews,
the evidence is clear.
Immigrants trying to reach countries
with high levels of freedom and more
open economic systems in shorts,
places where they can work and enjoy
life without fear.
Therefore perhaps a good measure and
maybe the only one to control the
migrator reflow.
It's a remote trade,
private investments and democratic
institutions in the countries that
people are leaving,
that's meanwhile developed countries can
take advantage of immigration in the
same way as other societies throughout
history,
immigrants view,
uh,
they want to work and then wants to
prosper,
right?
So I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos.
And also don't forget to check out our
friends at reconsider media.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine.
And don't forget,
as I said this channel,
it's all possible because of patriotism
and our patrons on that platform.
Please do consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
And as always,
thank you for watching.
The United States will not be a migrant
camp and it will not be a refugee
holding facility.
Won't be.